so you know a lot of time managers ceos
executives don't know what to do when
one of their employees comes and asks
for a raise and you screw it up there
are certain situations where somebody
asks you for a raise in a certain way
you ought to say absolutely not and move
on but there are certain circumstances
and the way they do it you ought to
actually entertain the idea we're going
to talk about that today
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so stick around to the variant to
get a pdf of exactly what to do when
someone's coming and asking for a raise
but let's let's unpack this whole
conversation of what happens when people
come and ask you for it first of all if
you're a small business the employee's
going to come and ask you for a raise
because you got three four five
employees right but if you're running a
decent sized business say 500 employees
it's generally going to be one of your
managers that's going to come up to you
saying hey bobby ask for raise what
should we do etc etc so it's either
bobby asks manager manager brings up to
c-suite c-suite says we got a guy here
that's asking for race okay or your
middle management's going to ask the
c-suite and the c-suite brings it up to
you or the c-suite says hey i kind of
want to talk to you here's what i'm
looking at so depending on size of
business circumstances can change but
here's a few things to be thinking about
so anytime anyone's coming and asking
you for a raise put everybody in four
different categories one category is
high trust high specialized this is
somebody you trust this is somebody
that's very good employee for you
they're a superstar they're rock star
they're kicking ass they're doing so
good for the company that almost they
should never ask you for a raise you
should give them a raise okay you out of
right now watch this video and say let
me make a list of the guys that i want
to go up to and give them a raise and
you go do that
it's not good for them to come and ask
you for a raise okay but remember this
is highly specialized highly trust
positive attitude reliable workers going
above and beyond been with you for a
while they've made money they got
results they got everything to do with
data with attitude with developing
leaders up here second one is the people
that you have that maybe you're not
aware of that somebody may be
recommending they're doing a good job
they're not the highest they're not the
highest specialized not the highest
trust reliable but they're good
employees that you have then it's those
that if they ask you for rates you can
let them go if they don't ask you four
ways they're gonna do their job maybe
you'll just give a three to five percent
raise
and a small bonus then it's the bottom
one of people that you kind of got to be
proactive and fire and let them go right
so whoever asked you for rates first
things first you put them in different
boxes the first one second one third one
fourth one okay so that's that part now
obviously whichever one it falls in you
know what to do and you have to make a
decision of what to do with that
individual but let me go a little bit
deeper than that so somebody comes and
asks you for raise immediate reaction
let's see how they're asking you for the
race if they say something like this to
you
one of my uh uh uh employees and i've
been walking in business for 20 some
years now and i watch how people ask me
for a race and i watch how some of them
did it every year well i had one example
of a guy that would do it in the
following way every year and i didn't
know at this time how to handle it every
year he would say i got a job offer from
this recruiter that they're willing to
pay me 80 000 and you're only paying me
sixty thousand but if you pay me eighty
i'll stick around oh my god what do i do
in the situation here so i give him the
eighty then i notice second year guess
what he did same exact script there's a
there's a company that just reached out
to me and they're willing to offer me a
hundred thousand dollars and if you
don't give this to me you know i mean
you know i love this company but i'm
like oh [ __ ] so i went to honor do you
know what eventually happened to me with
this person they used the same tactic
four times until i finally said nope i
suggest you take the job and you move on
all the best to you because that person
was never all in that person was just
using that tactic and years later i
found out that we had an executive that
was teaching everybody on how to come
ask me for a raise and it was in a way
to ask for the race but with threats and
another offer and the ceo gets cornered
and seo doesn't know what to do then the
c-suite executive or the middle
management wasn't really a seasonal but
a management person would come up to me
and say well listen if you don't we
really need this person we really need
this person we really need this person
two years after that person left the
three people came and told me how that
person coached them on how to come and
ask me for a raise and they would have
their back so what does this mean to you
sometimes your structure
of how you give people a raise
if you don't have structure
your management is going to create the
structure on how to get a
raises because if you're the ceo if
you're the person to run the company
there's management here and then there's
everybody else that's asking for the
race and they go through this person if
you are not on the same values and
principles this person is creating it to
everybody because he or she is trying to
keep loyalty from these guys and the way
they keep loyalty it's not high level
leadership it's actually very low level
leadership they do it the following way
don't worry i'm going to help you get a
raise here's how to go ask pat for
raising papa papa here's how to go ask
johnny for the race first talk to a
recruiter and get some kind of an offer
letter from another company and then
give it to me and then i'm going to go
and say i think we're going to lose this
person so here's eventually what
happened
i paid attention to all the managers i
had and say they all have 10 15 20
different employees
why was one of them getting more people
coming to me with a threat of leaving
over others then i said something's a
little bit fishy here someone's
trainings do you understand what i'm
saying someone's training them on how to
come and ask me for a raise so then i
went and had a conversation with the
level management that manager then i
started calling everybody that was
asking for raise directly overlapping
them just have a conversation so tell me
um
how did you get in con how did the
recruiter get a hold of you
uh
you know it's just um
yeah how did you find out about the
recruiter well you know this this i said
okay so then i created criterias and
here's what the criterias are
seven pointer create a seven pointer
employee for yourself whatever the seven
pointers may be extremely specialized
number two extreme high attitude number
three always show up on time citizenship
right number four you know
there are great leaders they develop
other leaders number five you know it's
somebody that's been around the company
for two years who's constantly gone
above and beyond whatever create your
own seven pointer and then tell yourself
when people are going through this i'm
willing to make an offer to people that
are five pointers or higher not anybody
below a five-pointer right number two
get all your management to be on the
same page when it comes down to offers
because if somebody comes to you
and tells you they got an offer from
another company and you give them that
offer back they're gonna come back again
six months from now 12 months from now
18 months from now we had somebody three
years ago
got hired two months later we gave him
the 20 000 raise because that person
moved up to a different department
changed their profile on linkedin right
when they change your profile on
linkedin contacted a recruiter saying
i'm now such and such position the
recruiter found them a 90 uh 8 000 your
job with 30 000 bonus then they came up
and said if you don't give me this
position i'm gonna go over here then
eventually i said i'm not giving you a
raise anymore it's done because just
three months ago you were at such and
such now you're asking me for this now
you're playing games i don't appreciate
that we're good to go we wish you
nothing but the best go ahead oh no no
no i wasn't really taking that job oh
you're not no i'm not you're not taking
a job i'm not taking the job so now
you're not taking a job i'm not taking
the job
so then that's when i know this is not
the right person we have to move on and
go find somebody else and we have to
replace her and we got somebody else to
move on the company here's what you have
to realize the more clear you are about
this process when people come to you the
better you're going to do people are
going to come and recommend i prefer
recommendations this is what i prefer i
prefer a management coming and
recommending somebody to get xyz every
single year this is how we do it i go
through a list of all our employees we
have a clear structure on bonuses and
management will come up to me and say i
believe this person hit this person at
their goals 25 was linked to ebitda
profits 25 was linked to top line
revenue we hit our goals the other 25
was their okr and the other 25 was
whatever they get 50 the goal which is
20 their salary you're making 60 grand
12
20 is 12 grand 50 is six grand here's
six thousand dollar bonus awesome job
johnny for the work you did this year by
hitting your criterias right and then i
think this person deserves a five
percent raise i think this person
there's a ten percent raise i think
there's a new position i want to move
this person great leaders at the top
ought to be thinking about how to help
their guys move up constantly that's
what great leaders at the top do when
you do that you're moving people up
ain't nobody thinking about other offers
some people are going to go out there
and work at places to get a resume to
constantly get better jobs and get
salaries and they're not really the best
employees they just know how to work the
game they're eventually going to get
caught just so you know the market
doesn't favor people like that because
if let's just say you're worth only 60
but someone's paying you 110 you're
eventually gonna get exposed and get
fired and you think you know what's
worse than i was able to land a hundred
ten thousand out of your job are you
really only a sixty thousand dollar your
specialty guy you're eventually gonna
come down here it's very embarrassing
when people realize this because that's
when people start putting in their
resumes a gap yeah i took a year and a
half off to take care of my mom because
she was sick no during that year and a
half you had three jobs and none of them
worked out because people realize you're
full of it and that's why you said you
had a year and a half yeah people are
eventually going to figure out who the
best employees are and who the best
talents is and those guys are going to
be fine the rest are going to get
filtered out it always happens when the
market is doing good people get lucky
and land good salaries
but if you cannot perform
on the expectation that you have you'll
eventually be fired so again this is
going to happen when people do come up
here and somebody's asking you for a
raise ask him can you put it in an email
and tell me why
how do you think you qualify to get a
raise here's what was expected of me
this is what i've done the last 12
months here's what i improved in this
area here's what i've done in this area
i think for this i'm asking for this i
love the company i love being here if
you notice words that are threatening
words don't negotiate with threatening
words if you don't i already have five
other jobs lined up you just tell them
listen man it's awesome can you imagine
you're dating somebody and they say look
i love you i'd love to marry you but if
you don't i got three other guys that
are waiting for me to date them but i
really love you babe i really want to be
with you like wait what you got three
guys let me call them for you right now
go
i wish you nothing but the best i never
had you in the first place right so you
have to be aware of that while you're
hiring retaining and working with people
who are asking for race so i talk about
a lot of different things if you want
all of this on a pdf click over here to
subscribe and get the whole pdf and
number two if you want to watch another
video that has to do with how for you to
ask for a raise click on this video to
learn how you can ask your boss for
raise take care everybody bye
[Music]